[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAK LAKSHMANAN:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
My name is Lak, and I'm
going to be talking today
about public data
sets on Google Cloud.
We have Googlers available on
standby to answer questions.
So please ask questions
on the platform.
So when we've talking
about public data sets,
we, of course, start
at what's available?
What kind of public
data sets are there?
There are essentially
three different types
of public data on Google Cloud.
The first of them
are the data sets
that are on Google BigQuery.
BigQuery is, of course, the
data warehouse in Google Cloud.
It's a good place to store
structured data sets,
because you can query
them using standard SQL.
You get querying
up to 1 terabyte
per month for no charge.
And to just show you the kinds
of things that are available,
I'll go to this website--
console.cloud.go
ogle.com/marketplace.
So I'll go into the marketplace.
And you can scroll down
and you see that there
are data sets available.
But instead of going ahead and
clicking on these data sets,
I could basically go ahead
and say, let me go ahead
and find New York City 311 data.
So 311 in New York City is
where New Yorkers call in
with complaints--
municipal complaints.
So we can go there, click on
this data set, and, in addition
to viewing the data
set, there are a couple
of example queries available.
So let's go ahead.
And this sounds
very interesting.
Which New York boroughs have
the most number of parties?
If you decide to
move to New York,
where do you want to go live?
So let's go ahead
and run this query.
And what I'll do is I will
go ahead, wait for the query
to load.
And this is the classic UI.
But I love the new
UI in BigQuery.
So let me go ahead and
switch to the new UI.
So that is the query.
And let me go ahead
and run the query.
And there we go.
The query basically says--
matter of seconds-- that
the borough is in Brooklyn,
we had 110,000 or more
parties, and so on.
And this is the different
party days, 1 being Sunday
and 7 being Saturday.
And as you would expect,
most of the parties
are on Saturdays and
Sundays, although Manhattan
seems to have some parties
on Fridays as well.
So where are the
really loud parties?
Well, one thing that we
did was we just went ahead
and did the query.
But let's go in and
do something cooler.
Let's go in and explore
this data in Data Studio.
So what this is doing is that
it's going ahead and running
this query for us.
And I will change.
Right now, this is basically
based on the record count.
So let me go ahead
and change the metric
to be the number of parties.
And instead of doing the
sum, let me choose the max.
And let's change this
to be a bar chart.
And there we go.
Brooklyn has the most number of
parties, followed by Manhattan,
followed by Queens.
And we saw how easy it was to go
from a data set to do a query,
and to go ahead and display
it using Data Studio.
So what was
different about this?
And it's kind of good
to step back and say,
OK, what exactly was different?
So sure, I showed you going to a
website, running the SQL query,
and then going to
another website
and visualizing the data
all in one workflow.
So, great.
But the key thing
that's different
here is that the data didn't
actually move anywhere.
The data was there in BigQuery.
It was there on
the Google Cloud.
And what we did was that
we brought a whole bunch
of compute to this data.
So if you were to go
to this data set--
so let's go ahead and
view the data set.
And let's see.
There is a 311 service request.
And look at the details
of this data set.
That was 8, almost
9 gigs of data
that we queried in
a matter of seconds.
How is that possible?
The only reason
it's possible was
because we threw thousands of
machines on this one SQL query
to execute it.
And there was no way
that this data was
present on those compute nodes.
Instead, just like these
birds flocking over a sea,
we brought a bunch of machines
to go ahead and process
the data in a distributed form,
and give us the answer back.
So if you were to think of
what the old world was in terms
of data analysis,
the old world was
to go ahead and download data to
your laptop, analyze the data,
and then distribute the results.
But that old world doesn't
really work anymore.
And the reason it doesn't
work is that the kind of data
sets that we are now
dealing with are much, much,
much larger.
If you take an
industrial use case,
you're probably producing
anywhere from half a terabyte
to 4 terabytes per
machine per year.
Or health care, a typical
hospital of more than a
terabyte per month.
Or transportation, you have
about 2 gigs of data a year.
And if you're in retail,
you may be collecting up
to 4 gigs of data per
day per product line.
This is a lot of data.
And when you think
of that kind of data,
this old workflow of where you
start with downloading data,
it doesn't work anymore,
because data doesn't fit.
The other thing that
happens is that when
you want to do your
processing, there
is a lot more compute power
available on the cloud.
And especially when it gets into
things like machine learning.
What's shown here is a
Tensor Processing Unit--
a TPU-- a custom ASIC
for machine learning.
And if you want to do machine
learning on large data sets,
and do them in a
fast way, you need
to be able to access
hardware like this.
And at that point, thinking of
analyzing data on your laptop,
it doesn't really
work, because you
need lots of compute to be
able to do your analysis,
to do-- especially a
machine learning-- on data
sets this large.
And the third aspect of this
is that in the old world
you would distribute reports.
It was OK if you just
give somebody a PDF.
But these days, everyone is
used to interactive reports.
They want to be able to do
what I just did in Data Studio,
or what you do when
somebody sends you a map.
They don't send
you a PDF of a map.
They send you a Google
Map that you can then
go ahead and interact with.
And that's true of charts.
That's true of documents.
People are used to
interactive reports.
And so when you distribute the
results for your data analysis,
they need to be interactive.
And so the old world where
you downloaded the data,
analyze the data on your
laptop, and then email
your results as a PDF,
those don't work anymore.
So the new world
is a world in which
you need to analyze, share
your data, and do your reports.
And so what I just did in that
demo of finding the boroughs
in New York with the most
number of parties, that
illustrated this new world--
this new world where
the data stays in place,
and you bring your
analysis to it.
And that is what public data
sets on Google Cloud are about.
It's about the data
staying in place,
and being able to do massive
amounts of compute on the data,
and to be able to provide
the results of that analysis
in a form that your end users
can still play around with,
can interact with, can
query it themselves as well.
So the whole idea here is that
we started with a data set.
And having gotten
the data set, we
went ahead and
clicked on the query.
And then we ran the query.
And then we clicked on
exploring Data Studio.
And then I was in that
interactive report.
And I was able to go ahead
and change the way I displayed
the data and I did the data.
And all of this is possible.
And with Data Studio I
can share these things.
And it's all possible because
it's all on the cloud,
and the data remains in place.
I mean, there's no way you can
think of moving 9 gigs of data
around every time you want
to do analysis like this.
The data needs to stay in place.
And you need to bring
compute to the data.
But this is not
just about analysis.
So what I just showed you
with parties in New York
was about analysis.
But what's a new cool thing?
Machine learning.
And so even in BigQuery,
right, with our data sets,
we can actually train a
machine learning model.
And this time I'll pick a
data set also from New York
to predict a taxi fare.
So given the pickup location
and the drop-off location,
I would like to basically figure
out what would the taxi cost.
And in order to do that,
I will go back and look
at historical data of
all kinds of taxi trips,
and what was the actual
amount paid by passengers
taking those taxi trips.
And this will allow me
to demonstrate BigQuery
ML, and also BigQuery GIS.
Because this is a
special data set.
People get picked up at
specific locations, dropped off
at specific locations.
And rather than do it
from the user interface--
BigQuery user
interface-- this time
I'll do it from a
Python notebook.
And I'll also show
you another cool tool
called a geomapper or Geo Viz.
So going down here.
So this is a GitHub
repository that
contains a taxi fare model.
So this is a Python notebook.
I just loaded it into a Datalab,
which is a Python notebook
environment.
I can go ahead and, in
Datalab, I can click on a cell,
and I can run the cell.
And this allows me to run it.
And let's see.
So we can go down here,
do the Python imports.
And here now is
my BigQuery query.
So the key part of
this query is that I'm
selecting some number of rows
from a table of New York City
taxi trips.
So I can go ahead and run that.
And then I can say, go ahead
and execute this query.
And I get 1,000 of them.
And I can look at
the top few records.
And there's my trips.head.
And so on.
And so we can go ahead and
look at the description
of those things.
But that is, at this point,
just still data analysis.
So let's look at this line.
This is the line that
does the machine learning.
So I take your query
that pulls in records.
And in this case,
I'm pulling records
that contain the hour of the
day, the pick-up longitude,
the pick-up latitude,
the drop-off
longitude, the drop-off
latitude, all of which
come from the data.
And the total fare
that was paid.
And that also comes
from the data--
the total fare being
the actual fair amount
plus any tolls, et cetera.
So those are the columns.
And I say, please go ahead and
create a machine-learning model
to predict the taxi fare using
a linear regression model.
And the rest of these
things are optional.
So we can do that.
And at this point
we can go ahead
and say, run this query for me.
I don't want to overwrite
the query I already have.
So I'll call this Demos2.
And I'll go ahead and
say, run the query.
Oh, I need to run
this [? cell, ?]
and then run the query.
And we can then go ahead
and execute the query.
And this takes about
5 to 10 minutes.
So I'll let that execute.
And I'll assume that
it's already done.
And I'll just move on to what
you would get at the end of it.
So after that, what you will
get is that in BigQuery there
will be a model that's created
that is capable of doing
this prediction.
And notice that all
that we really did
was that we took
a normal BigQuery
query that did the standard
SQL and added three lines.
Go ahead and create the model
with this particular algorithm
to predict this column based
on all these other columns.
And at that point, we also
get back the training loss.
As the error decreases
as the model trains,
we can evaluate it on
another independent data set.
So this is just
another BigQuery query
where I'm doing a select
from an ML that evaluate.
And then I can go ahead
and look at the errors.
And the errors turn out
to be about $6 on average.
And then we can also go
ahead and evaluate it
based on, OK, so we have
$6 on average error.
But does the error
change depending
on where people were
picked up, or where
people were dropped off?
And so what I can do is that
I can go ahead and select
the total fare.
I can go ahead and find
the error and group it
by dollars, group it
by the amount of fare.
And if I did that, I
would find that the errors
are really small when
the fair is around $11.
And it increases
quadratically on each side.
So it basically, on
very expensive trips,
and very cheap trips,
the errors are very high.
And so this is, well, we
need to do something else.
So what I'll do is I'll go
ahead and add the ST underscore
geographic point, which is
a spatial query in BigQuery.
So this allows me to basically
treat the pick-up longitude
and pick-up latitude not
as two independent points,
but at one point--
a pick-up point.
And having gotten
that pick-up point,
then I will go ahead and
compute the distance--
ST_Distance-- between the
pickup and drop-off point.
And I'll use that as one
of my training variables.
So even though this is not
present in the original data,
I'm now using some
geospatial functions
to go ahead and
create a new feature.
And when I do that, long
story short, my errors
become very flat across
all of these dollar ranges.
So I'm actually learning
to predict much better.
And then let's go
ahead and visualize it.
And let's now let's look
at how these errors change
based on location.
So what I'm going
to do is that I'm
going to basically take this
query, which what it does
is that it groups these
things by drop-off grid point.
And I'll go to the
BigQuery Geo Viz,
and put my project ID in there.
And say that I want
to run that query.
[INAUDIBLE] And run that query.
OK.
So there it is.
So I see the results.
And I'll change it to
the drop-off grid point.
And I see my results here.
Let me go ahead and
change the style,
and change the fill color to
be data-driven, and make it
a linear interval.
And let's go ahead and do
the range of that color.
And maybe from 0 to 20.
And the field could be
the mean absolute error.
And let's go ahead and do that.
And you see that the
colors are different.
But at this point,
my original data,
the resolution is
actually pretty small,
because I did resolution
of 0.1 degrees.
Let me change that
to 0.01 degrees.
So now I get a lot more points.
I can go back to my style.
And there we go.
And as you can see--
let me change the
color a little bit.
Code.
So you can see that the
errors are low in Manhattan.
And as you go further
and further away
into Brooklyn, et cetera,
the errors increase.
And this is a kind
of visualization
that we did relatively
quickly on the map.
So let's move back here.
So, cool.
That was great.
I just trained a model--
machine-learning model--
based on a public data set--
the New York City
taxicab data set--
to predict taxi fare.
So I said, there's different
types of public data
sets available on Google Cloud.
I spent about 15 minutes.
I tracked on BigQuery.
So let's now talk about
what else is available.
So we started talking about
three types of public data.
The second type of
public data that's
available on Google Cloud
is the Google genomics data.
So genomics data
consists of two parts.
You have some data
sets in BigQuery.
These are things like
variants, et cetera.
You have another data
set on Cloud Storage.
These are like the BAM,
VCF files, and so on.
And there is a link if
you want to learn more.
But one of the things
that you could do
is that you could actually
go ahead and use BigQuery.
You could use BigQuery to
go ahead and run a query
like this, where you are
joining against your own table
against a thousand genome data
set, for example, to figure out
something about the variance.
And I won't embarrass
myself by talking too much
more about genomics, because I
don't know too much about it.
But there is a data set
where you can actually
compare a particular genome
that you have against one
of the public genomes.
The third type of
public data set that you
have are geospatial data sets.
Geospatial data sets
like Landsat images,
or NEXRAD images,
these are images
that are present on
Google Cloud Storage--
so not in BitQuery anymore,
but in Google Cloud storage.
In some cases a metadata.
What files are available?
What times are
available, et cetera,
are present in BigQuery.
But the actual data
themselves-- the raster data--
is on Cloud Storage.
And also we have, of course,
the Earth Engine data sets,
which is another huge amount
of geospatial data sets
that are available
for use as well.
So what is the point of this?
So I said initially
that public data sets
are about bringing
computer to the data.
And I showed that with
the case of BigQuery,
where we had these
large data sets,
and we were able to do SQL
queries on that data set.
Well, when you look at
geospatial data sets,
it's exactly the same way.
You have your public data
sets in cloud storage.
And you will be able to process
them with that data in place.
But this time, the
processing typically
happens in Cloud Dataflow.
Cloud Dataflow is an
execution environment
for Apache Beam pipelines.
And you can write
Apache Beam code
either in Python or in Java.
So you have two SDKs, two APIs.
So you write your code in
Apache Beam Python or Java.
And you run it in
Cloud Dataflow.
So it's loosely like how
you write standard SQL.
And you run it in BigQuery.
So you do Apache Beam, and
you run it in Dataflow.
And as an example,
so hurricanes are
in the news today in the
US, with Florence just
having been here.
So let's look at an earlier
hurricane, Hurricane Maria.
And I'll basically
show you how to process
weather data in real time
in BigQuery and in Dataflow.
So here is a blog post.
And I'll just walk
through it a little bit.
So there is a BigQuery
public data set
that consists of
NOAA hurricanes-- all
of the hurricanes
all over the world.
Basically you can
go ahead and get
the latitudes, the longitude,
the time that they were.
And in this case
I'm saying, find me
a hurricane whose name has
Maria in it, and from 2017,
and order it by ISO time.
So what I'm going to now get is
the full path of the hurricane.
So I have the latitude and
longitude that Maria was in,
and the time at which the
hurricane was at that location,
and how far away from landfall
was that particular hurricane.
So from this time
time step, what
I'm going to then do is
I'm going to go ahead
and look inside the Google
Cloud public data set.
I can go and say, find
out my satellite data
for that particular year
for that particular date.
And we can go ahead and pull up
the appropriate satellite data.
So we can go ahead, go
to this public bucket.
So this is a public bucket, and
this is where the public data
set comes in.
And we can pull up that
particular time stamp.
And having done that, this
is in a format called NetCDF.
And you have Python
code or Java libraries
to be able to read it.
So in this case, I'm
using the Python library
to read NetCDF files.
And I'm reading those,
and I'm plotting
those using Matplotlib.
So you can basically
go from BigQuery,
figure out what it is
that you want to access,
access the data using Python--
it's just a data
in cloud storage.
And you can do all of
the kinds of things
that you would normally
do with satellite data.
What gets interesting,
though, is
if you want to process large
amounts of data all at once.
And so that's where the next
part of this is showing.
So this is now an
Apache Beam pipeline.
What I'm saying, go ahead
and run this hurricane query.
And for every row of
the hurricane query,
find me all of the
[? ghost ?] files--
the satellite data files--
at this particular latitude and
at this particular longitude,
and convert them into JPEG.
So at that point, I will
then get on Dataflow
an auto-scaling
pipeline that processes.
And in this case, it's
getting all of the hurricanes
everywhere.
And then basically
creating a separate loop
for every one of the hurricanes,
a kind of distributed
processing that
allows you to process
terabytes of data at scale
over hundreds of machines
if you need to.
And this is the plot, for
example, of Hurricane Maria.
And the other
thing you can do is
that you can also
listen to Pub/Sub, which
is a real-time data feature.
Every time a new satellite
image hits cloud storage,
we publish an
event onto Pub/Sub.
So you can go into Pub/Sub, and
you can listen for that Pub/Sub
message.
And you can do some processing.
So what I'm doing here is I'm
doing very simple processing.
I'm basically going
ahead and cropping out
a part of the image that
corresponds to Seattle.
And I'm basically saying,
here is a satellite image
over Seattle at this
current point in time.
But as with the
hurricane data, you
can do this for
every city in the US.
You can do it for
different areas.
You can create loops.
You can do all of
those kinds of things.
And the cool thing is you
can do them all in real time.
So with that, I'll basically
leave you with some resources.
First of all, shameless
plug for my book.
If you're interested in doing
data analysis data science
machine learning
on Google Cloud,
there is a O'Reilly book, "Data
Science on the Google Cloud
Platform," written
by yours truly.
The second thing is
that we have a number
of courses on Coursera.
And if you're
watching this webinar,
go to coursera.org/NEXTExtended,
and you will get one month
of courses free on the platform.
So please take advantage of it.
And finally, if
you go to Qwiklabs,
there's a variety of labs,
including many of the things
that I demonstrated,
[? RS ?] labs
that you can try out yourself.
And that's a wrap.
Stay tuned for live Q&A. We'll
be back in about a minute.
Welcome back.
So I'm taking
questions right now.
So if you have more
questions, please add them
to the platform.
So first question, how often
are these public data sets
updated to reflect new data?
Great question.
There are some data sets.
For example the satellite
data that I just showed you.
That satellite data
streams into the cloud.
And so we actually have
new data every time
there's a new image that's
downloaded from the satellite.
So if you're taking over a full
disk, it's every 15 minutes.
But lots of times you have
new data every minute.
So it is near real time for
cases like Landsat data,
for cases like Sentinel, for
cases like the [? ghost ?]
data.
For the BigQuery data sets,
also if you're thinking,
for example, the
city bikes data,
or the [? ghost ?] temperature,
or the [? gsort ?] temperature
data, the weather data, all
of those kinds of things,
as and when new data is
available from the public data
set provider, that data is
reflected on Google Cloud
as well.
So the answer to how often
are these public data
sets updated, it is like we
try to keep them as up to date
as we can.
Some data sets, like
the zip codes data set,
we might update once a
year, the utility data sets.
But for the most part,
as a rule of thumb,
the public data sets
are as up to date
as the provider of the public
data sets allows us to be.
Second question.
How do you decide
which data sets
to feature on your
public data sets program?
This is where you can help.
If you have suggestions
on what data
sets we should be
featuring, data
sets that you would find
useful, please do let us know.
And remember that even though
I talked about public data sets
on Google Cloud, there
is a lot of public data
available out there.
There is data on Earth Engine.
There's data on Kaggle.
And for, to some extent, our
goal with the Google Cloud
public data sets program
is to focus on data
sets where it's large enough,
or it's useful enough that--
So, number one, it's very large.
So you need to bring
compute to the data.
So we want to basically feature
it to make it easier for folks.
The second reason is that
it's a very useful data set.
Like the zip code data
set is not very large.
But it is an extremely
useful data set.
So we will have it as
a utility data set,
so each individual company
doesn't have to do that.
So we either do it
as a public good,
or we do it as because it's
a very large computing, even
though genomics data is
not very widely used,
but it's very useful,
and it's very large.
So we tend to feature it.
And so the way we decide
is please let us know.
And if you're a
provider of data,
and you would like your data
to be featured on Google Cloud,
also do contact us.
There's two ways to do it.
We can do the public data set.
But we can also do the Google
Cloud Marketplace, which allows
you to monetize your data set.
Third question.
You showed a number of links.
How can I get a
copy of your slides
so that I can visit
those websites?
Good point.
If you stick around
in the Q&A, we
will post a link
to my presentation
so that you can
actually get access.
And then you can
go to that link.
And then all of the other
links are available.
So feel free to explore.
My deck has lots
and lots of links.
And each of them is
a great set of things
to go ahead and explore.
So strongly encourage
you to do that.
Fourth question.
That's a cool one.
BigQuery and machine
learning seems very cool.
When should I use BigQuery
ML versus TensorFlow?
That's a great question.
So I just showed
you BigQuery ML.
A little bit of SQL,
and you basically
have a machine-learning model.
It's amazing.
So what's all this thing about
this whole TensorFlow stuff?
Do we need it?
What is it about?
Well, the thing to
realize is, number one,
BigQuery ML is about
structured data.
And in many ways, if your
data set is very large,
and it's very sparse--
in other words, there's a
lot of categorical columns--
BigQuery ML will be very
competitive with a TensorFlow
model.
So BigQuery ML would be
great for large data sets
with lots of columns,
and especially
lots of categorical columns
that have lots of values--
what I'll call a
sparse data set.
For all other types of data,
TensorFlow is a great choice.
So if you have image data,
you have time series data,
you have dense
data sets, you have
data sets that involve a
mixture of these things,
TensorFlow is a much more
flexible, powerful framework.
The way I like to
think of BigQuery ML
is that BigQuery ML is a
great way by which, rather
than writing TensorFlow code to
write a machine learning model,
you get to express your
machine learning model in SQL.
So think of BigQuery as
SQL is the user interface.
And in the future I
can easily imagine
a world in which you
write your model in SQL,
but it doesn't get
executed in BigQuery ML.
Instead, it gets executed in
TensorFlow on Cloud ML engine.
But the way you express
your model could be a SQL.
So maybe you want to do
the separation between SQL
as a UI, which is very,
very, very attractive;
and SQL as the execution
engine, which may or may not
be limited in what it can do.
But I agree with you.
BigQuery ML is super cool.
Final question, looks like.
Are public data sets available
to be used on other cloud
providers' platform also?
A good question.
So the public sets are public.
So, many of them,
you can access them.
But something like
a BigQuery data
set, you would have
to transfer the data.
I cannot imagine how you
would be able to use that from
another cloud provider.
On the other hand, the Google
Cloud Storage data sets,
you can absolutely.
You can access it from another
cloud service provider.
But typically there
might be an egress fee
involved, because you're
actually crossing a network.
But other than that, yes.
So if there is a public
data set on Google Cloud,
on Cloud Storage, and you have
your code in some other cloud
service provider, you should
be able to access it the way
you would access any
other data on GCP.
So it is an open platform.
You will be able to access it.
And you should be able to do it.
So even if it isn't BigQuery.
And now one option might be to
basically run an extraction,
or run a query to extract a part
of the data set that you care
about, and then transfer that
data over, and process it
somewhere else on prem or in
some other cloud provider.
Any other questions?
All right.
And I guess that's a wrap.
Stay tuned for
the next session--
[? CETV-- ?] Application
Observability with Light Step.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]